[Musique]
salut Benjamin ça va
ouais ça va on vient juste d'arriver là
c'est tard le plus tôt enfin dès qu'on
peut vous retrouver c'est
le mieux on peut pas partir avec vous
8h20 ok parfait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
c'est le la fouille de Bibracte ici ok
merci
en fait c'est une fouille au départ qui
est Dijon Besançon et puis Martine qui
maintenant est à Toulouse donc c'est des
gens Besançon Toulouse parce que il
fouille depuis vraiment très longtemps
en tout cas depuis 2010 plus de 10 ans
ils ont commencé sur le site qui est
juste derrière nous qui est PC15 là on
est sur le site qui s'appelle PC 14 pc
pour parc aux chevaux
de l'oppidum qui date du 19e siècle les
premiers fouilleurs de l'epidum qui sont
bulliaux puis ensuite d'échelettes il
pensait que c'était des grandes
plateformes qui étaient destinées à
faire d'être les chevaux de la cavalerie
et duène la fameuse cavalerie et duenne
qui a été César et donc il avait
interprété ça comme ça alors c'était le
19e ils interprété enfin 19e début 20e
c'est des interprétations un peu tirées
par les cheveux le nom a été gardé en
fait on se rend compte que c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça
pibracte se situe au sommet du Mont
Beuvray en Bourgogne
c'est un oppidum gaulois c'est-à-dire un
site d'habitat fortifié sur un point
haut dont les remparts sont aujourd'hui
sous la forêt
capital des édus 1 pendant un siècle la
cité se transforme après la conquête des
Gaules par César en 52 avant
Jésus-Christ les archéologues le
constatent notamment par l'apparition de
domus des maisons urbaines typiquement
romaines
des domus comme ça ça fait très
longtemps qu'on en a pas fouillé on
essaye aussi de compléter la
connaissance de l'organisation de tout
ce quartier qui est à la fois un
quartier donc avec un centre public et
puis un quartier peut-être culturel
parce qu'on appelle la dernière nous le
taureau de la roche au 19e siècle on a
trouvé une une inscription à mercure on
suppose un peu le
sanctuaire la fonction religieuse du
secteur et sachant que sur le site et
bien on voit peu à peu s'installer les
techniques de construction à la romaine
que ce soit dans dans l'habitat donc que
soit dans le domaine privé comme dans le
domaine public
et c'est ça qui est hyper intéressant
ici c'est que c'est vraiment un modèle
de romanisation notamment de
l'architecture de l'évolution en fait
d'une ville qui est fondamentalement
gauloise et qui passe d'un coup juste
après la guerre des Gaules à une ville
avec plein d'archétypes qui sont
typiquement romains mais qui sont pas
destinés à recevoir des Romains qui sont
destinés aux élites et duen en fait qui
sont déjà romanisés depuis longtemps et
qui parlent latin qui séjournent à Rome
c'est tout l'intérêt et l'intelligence
en fait des Romains c'est de proposer un
système d'intégration qui est
extrêmement pratique en tout cas pour
les élites rapides et qui fonctionne
très très bien et on le voit en fouille
en tout cas en tant qu'archéologue tu le
vois vraiment d'une d'une cité à l'autre
ce qu'on appelle des cités états en tout
cas entre les étudiants les sékouanes
aller très vite les dingons etc etc ceux
qui n'ont pas le même traité tu sens au
niveau de la fouille que la monétisation
elle se fait de manière décaler des fois
de deux à trois générations alors qu'il
y a 50 km d'écart entre entre les deux
territoires mais il y a des frontières
culturelles
et politiques et qui fait que des fois
ça se développe plus vite que d'autres
et c'est ici que le développement débute
pour les goals en tout cas dans la
période romaine
allié de rhum depuis longtemps les
aidants sont les premiers Gaulois à
adopter le mode de vie romain grâce aux
étroites relations commerciales qu'ils
entretiennent avec l'Italie ils
importent du vin de l'huile et de
nombreux produits de la Méditerranée
Bibracte devient naturellement l'une des
portes d'entrée de l'urbanisme romain
après le but était donc de fouiller
cette année une maison qui est plutôt
située dans la partie immédiane et sud
de la foudre et une problématique en
fait c'est que la dernière phase de
construction du break elle donne
l'impression que
les gens ont lancé des chantiers de
construction et puis la décision était
prise de partir à hautain et les
bâtiments venaient soit juste déterminer
mais qui ont quasiment pas été occupés
voire pas occupé du tout mais il y a
sans doute même des secteurs qui étaient
encore en chantier et c'est extrêmement
intéressant de réfléchir à quels sont
les moyens mis en oeuvre dans ces
premières villes autoron à l'époque
gauloise qu'à l'époque romaine pour
justement construire la ville penser la
ville avoir une vraie vision
urbanistique de l'ensemble
en fait la particularité de biberette
c'est qu'on est sur un socle granitique
qui est extrêmement acide et en fait on
retrouve par exemple jamais de phone on
a aucun os sur le site à part s'ils ont
brûlé le sol dévore tout et de la même
manière le sol dévore la chaux bien tu
as les petites boulettes là les racines
c'est vraiment caractéristiques quand tu
arrives soit sur un mur soit sur un sol
en fait c'est que du coup avec les
infiltrations d'eau le sédiment s'en va
il reste plus que les éléments qui sont
à l'intérieur et ça c'est un bon un bon
tips pour arriver à reconnaître un petit
peu les vestiges tu vois là tu as
vraiment la limite du mur là elle est
propre
on te faire les études moi ce qui
m'intéressait de l'époque romaine
pendant les cours ils ont commencé à
nous parler de l'âge de Bron on a vu le
faire je connaissais rien du tout pas
grand chose en fait il faut exprès de
donner envie aux étudiants ces
époques-là parce que c'est les
disciplines assez nouvelles c'est là où
il y a un peu de la mine quoi
sur 10 étudiants il y en a 8
qu'on échange de trouver une place plus
tard bah en fait le taxi
en Allemagne
j'ai repris les études il y a 2 ans que
j'ai envie de
de faire autre chose quoi
avec les études on n'a pas toujours le
temps donc
ma mère qui me prête de l'argent et puis
il faut que je rembourse un peu
deux mois de fouille de mois de travail
pour passer pour la troisième
[Musique]
il montre comment on pioche sans se
faire mal au dos
[Musique]
c'est l'avantage ici programmée c'est
qu'on a le temps on peut former les
étudiants déjà c'est l'objectif mais
surtout on a le temps de répondre aux
questions qu'on se pose et puis une
année on a pas fini on peut revenir
l'année prochaine si on a terminé on se
dit bah voilà on se posait cette
question on a répondu à ça mais il nous
reste encore tout ça à percevoir et à
comprendre et bien on va essayer
d'ouvrir ici pour répondre à tel
problématique mais on n'est pas du tout
dans une logique de destruction pour
construire une autoroute un immeuble un
parking là on est au contraire dans une
logique de recherche on vient fouiller
parce qu'on se pose des problématiques
pas parce que le site va être détruit en
fait on est un peu comme des
scientifiques qui ont besoin d'un
passage en laboratoire pour acquérir de
la donnée puis ensuite la traiter nous
notre laboratoire c'est la fouille et
une fois qu'on a fouillé on va traiter
en fait toutes ces données mais par
défaut on sait qu'on archéologie on n'a
jamais toujours des conditions idéales
donc tout ce qu'on documente
c'est pas le meilleur moment c'est
toujours ça de prix parce que ce sera
peut-être pire après un exemple tiens si
vous venez avec moi je vous montre déjà
et puis après vous serez en autonomie
[Musique]
de la zone de fouille par exemple le
petit aménagement fort
si on peut déjà le photographier
maintenant celui qui est derrière donc
là vous fouettez les mecs un four qui
travaille proprement
que vous allez faire des photos vous
avez le droit de les engager
[Musique]
on doit décaisser le le fossé qui se
trouve ici là
du métal
du métal on est obligé de le
séparer de la céramique et de le mettre
dans un sachet qui doit être ouvert
obligatoirement sinon il peut s'oxyder
il était dans le dans
du coup
ça fait à peu près un an qu'on attend ça
donc effectivement faites d'autres
fruits ou pas
on est plutôt sur le quartier
résidentiel aristocratique de l'oppidum
il est très belle maison romaine des
domos donc les maisons aristocratiques
qui ont été fouillées un petit peu
partout
la maison c'est un espace de vie
politique économique et elle est en tout
cas acceptée et utiliser ce type
d'architecture ça veut dire aussi
rentrer dans une logique politique et
typiquement romaine et qui va trancher
avec les pratiques politiques
antérieures il y a sans doute peut-être
le plus ancien forum à des goals qui est
construit ici avec un édifice basilical
assez complexe qui date des années
peut-être 50-30 avant Jésus-Christ qui
montre aussi une évolution politique
très forte de la cité des aiguillages
une acceptation complète en fait de
des volontés politiques romaines pour
intégrer le plus vite possible la
population dans l'orbite et ça permet
vraiment de suivre toute l'évolution en
tout cas de la rédaction on va dire de
la Guerre des Gaules par César ici
jusqu'à l'intégration complète de la
Gaule dans l'Empire romain et qui
devient une des provinces qui va fournir
de nombreux sénateurs nombreux soldats
le blé les esclaves enfin bref etc une
province totalement intégré dans
l'Empire
une quinzaine d'années avant
Jésus-Christ l'empereur Auguste décide
d'offrir aux etuins frère de sang de
Rome une nouvelle capitale située en
plaine celle qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
hautain porte alors le nom d'Augusto
nounoum en hommage à l'empereur colonie
romaine exemplaire elle illustre avec
ses monuments publics et ses remparts la
romanisation qui est en marche en haut à
Bibracte les constructions cessent
parfois en plein chantier et tous les
habitants ou presque déménagent dans la
plaine
alors vibrate est peu à peu après
abandonner il y a quelques domos
quelques maisons qui restent mais tout
le monde va s'installer en ville et en
tout cas les notables vont s'installer
en ville puis au temps ils construisent
avec le droit d'avoir un rempart enfin
des choses comme ça des privilèges qui
sont donnés que à des villes
particulières même à des capitales
particulières si on fait le total des
civils qui ont le droit d'avoir un
rempart après la conquête romaine donc
vers on va dire -10 + 10 on sait pas
trop quand ça s'est passé le temps que
ça s'installe on arrive à moins d'une
dizaine en Gaule en dehors des colonies
vous avez du pillage sur ces feuilles là
pas tant que ça parce qu'il faut quand
même monter jusqu'ici et puis
ça circule un peu alors après pendant
l'hiver oui il peut y avoir des du
pillage un peu comme ailleurs et sachant
que nous pour pour utiliser cet appareil
on a on demande une autorisation de la
même manière que les
l'autorisation de fouilles on fait ça de
manière réglementée
c'est la règle c'est la règle pourquoi
toujours garder un terrain propre cadeau
[Musique]
on laisse des tas de déblais il se met à
pleuvoir donc derrière c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui va fouiller après soi c'est
à Lui d'évacuer votre déesse et quand
même pas très sympa pour les camarades
donc c'est une règle de base on fouille
proprement et on laisse sa zone de
fouille propre derrière soi
en face de la grande de mousse les
fouilleurs de Bibracte ont découvert il
y a une dizaine d'années un bâtiment
monumental dont la fonction reste
toujours mystérieuse en marche sur quoi
alors là alors là on marche sur l'angle
de ce qui est pour nous la découverte
principale sur cette fouille on a
identifié 4 voir 5 états donc ça ça fait
42 voilà 42 44 mètres de côté et ça je
crois que c'est quasiment 2500 à 3000
mètres carrés ça veut dire mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bâtiment et
ben ça c'est notre grande question la
seule chose que je peux vous dire c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'il n'est pas il
n'est pas un sanctuaire c'est pas un
espèce de culte puisqu'on a retrouvé
aucun des vestiges typiques des
pratiques cultuelles de cette période là
priori c'est pas un édifice militaire
puisqu'on a très très peu où on dehors
de manière très anecdotique d'éléments
de militaria mes manifestement on est de
façon certaine sur un édifice public
puisque quand on voit les dimensions de
ce bâtiment c'est pas du tout quelque
chose de civile et en plus de ça tous
les seuls qu'on appuie identifier à
l'intérieur de la cour ou à l'intérieur
des espaces périphériques sont tous
nettoyés on n'a pas de poubelles
quasiment pas de rejet de rejets
domestiques ce qui fait qu'on a beaucoup
de difficultés à identifier la fonction
réelle de ce bâtiment
notre hypothèse la plus sérieuse c'est
que ça puisse être effectivement des une
place de marché une place d'échange donc
on ne laisse pas de poubelle on nettoie
après et on revient intervalles
réguliers voir peut-être permanente ce
qui est très original en plus dans cette
découverte c'est que c'était difficile
il est reconstruit très très
régulièrement donc il est édifié sur un
murus galicus donc sur une terrasse
artificielle et il est fort probable que
au bout d'une dizaine d'années cette
terrasse a commencé de s'affaisser lui
les intempéries le temps et bah sur
l'architecture bois ça fait vite des
ordres donc le bâtiment bouge se déforme
et impose de le démonter comme il est
important bon on le refait on peut pas
le refaire jamais exactement au même
endroit donc on va déplacer les poteaux
on va décaler et puis au lieu de faire
une galerie à 29 on va en faire une un
peu plus grande à une seule nef mais on
refait le même puis cette fois on va un
petit peu le complexifier on va mettre
autour une petite palissade ou
simplement une évacuation des autres
toitures 10 ans après à nouveau bon là
on suppose qu'un changement cette fois
de politique on va remplacer le système
de galerie couvrir la cour mais plus du
tout la galerie périphérique et plus du
tout le préau et dans le dernier état
celui dont on a une partie de visible là
devant nous et ben on va le remplacer
par une architecture de Pierre donc on
remplace la palissade bois par un mur
avec un grand bâtiment a priori sur
galerie à l'intérieur vous avez suivi
toute la folie donc moi j'ai fait les
campagnes de 2013 à 2018 donc c'est 6
années de fouilles successives pour
réussir à reconnaître les 3000 m² 3 4
mm² d'architecture de cet édifice
[Applaudissements]
ce matin j'ai vu que tu apprenais à
piocher à une jeune fille du coup il y a
vraiment des gens qui démarrent là cette
semaine
et puis après la semaine dernière ils
ont fait peut-être que de la truelle ils
ont pas vu la pioche et apprendre à
manier les outils c'est la base parce
que tu te fais mal très très vite en
fait c'est pour ça que moi je prends les
étudiants 4 semaines minimum pour qu'ils
aient le temps de tout faire et qu'ils
aient le temps de voir d'apprendre en
deux semaines ils apprennent pas tu
commences à être vraiment dans la dans
l'archéologie en fait à partir de 3-4
semaines en général l'année dernière je
découvrais bibrac pendant deux semaines
j'étais perdu c'est le tout le monde a
besoin de s'approprier chaque terrain
est différent il faut se l'approprier
chaque sédiment est différent chaque
contexte conservation de vestiges ça
prend du temps à s'habituer 1 2 3 4
donc tu veux tu fais bien les relations
ensemble et alors là on va commencer à
faire des paquets qui vont être liés les
uns avec les autres dans la pièce en
elle-même
et biberg c'est un site très difficile
alors déjà parce que le terrain naturel
est très très change donc on a rarement
un terrain qui est uniforme et homogène
ensuite le terrain est très agressif il
nous mord les doigts il nous mord les
genoux et c'est plein de cailloux donc
ça fait mal au dos ça fait mal aux mains
enfin c'est réellement un métier
physique le mythe de l'archéologue et
son pinceau c'est c'est une catastrophe
quoi comme outil de l'archéologue sur
une pelleteuse donc bon déjà ça pose les
bases
[Musique]
les offres des maisons ont été
abandonnés
étaient dans les maisons et à un moment
donné ça a été abandonné les gens sont
partis et ils ont pas emmené avec eux
les enfants
toutes les bouteilles en plastique avec
toi et tes bouteilles de rhum avoir une
généralement on a une étape de
redistribution en cruche en tout cas en
contenant plus petit qui permet
véritablement d'utiliser le handicap de
servir le vin et le consommer alors
forcément le gros conteneur qui arrive
ici et ça arrive par bateau entier des
centaines de milliers de tonnes
d'enfants c'est gigantesque et ça c'est
génial en fait c'est un matériau génial
ça permet de transporter des produits de
manière sérieuse solide sur puis une
fois que c'est là on peut le réutiliser
pour plein plein de choses les pense
bien à plat ça fait des supersolles de
foyer ça peut permettre de construire
plein d'éléments il y a un trou à
boucher en concasse des enfants en
bouche un trou c'est réutiliser donc
c'est pour ça qu'il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup c'est que la perception moi que
j'en aurais c'est objet précieux c'est
pas précieux
l'équivalent des bouteilles en plastique
et ou des bouteilles qu'on nous on jette
tous les jours et dont on sait pas quoi
faire
[Musique]
les autres ils ont eu le karcher hier
mais ça va pas marcher visiblement on a
regardé ce qu'ils ont fait hier et
finalement il y a ça de terre sur les
sur les objets c'est un scandale donc
voilà la bonne vieille brosse quoi
d'aller sur le chantier alors qu'il fait
30 degrés quoi c'est bien
une fois que tu as lavé ça comme ils
sont en train de faire faut les mettre à
sécher donc quand il fait beau et chaud
tu peux les mettre dehors et ça sèche
tout seul et sinon en général tu peux
les mettre dans une étude c'est un
espèce de four qui chauffe doucement et
c'est important quand même de les sécher
on est conditionnés fragiliser pareil
pour tout ce qui est objet métallique il
faut les faire sécher légèrement avant
de les conditionner pour tout simplement
pour empêcher le phénomène d'oxydation
pour elle d'accord voilà la tâche que tu
préfères sur un chantier par exemple moi
j'ai fait beaucoup de murs sur le
chantier là au cours des deux dernières
semaines
et j'ai des tours et les pierres c'est à
dire les rendre plus visibles pour les
photos etc et ça j'ai vraiment aimé
parce que ça ça mixe la violence parce
que il faut utiliser la pioche mais en
même temps la dédicatesse et à la fin
quand tu regardes ton mur bah tu es très
très content genre moi je passe devant
le chantier quand on arrive en fouille
le matin
la forme en fait de chaque morceau ça
permet de reconnaître après le type
auquel on fera appartient et puis de
constatate aussi parfois on arrive à
déterminer tout ça ce qui me faisait
d'ailleurs aussi assez réagir c'était
les moments où on voit un petit bout et
la personne dit automatiquement ça c'est
une tuile et pour moi c'est un bout de
terre cassé quoi les enfants et les
tuiles c'est pas forcément évident c'est
pour ça qu'on est nettoie parce que
quand c'est ça le tu arrives pas à bien
voir l'intérieur mais par exemple la
différence majoritaire c'est que déjà
c'est au niveau de la couleur ça a pas
exactement la même couleur dans les deux
cas c'est rouge mais l'enfant elle va
être un peu plus rosée là-dessus d'un
peu plus rouge brique
c'est assez rigoureux les morceaux sont
assez épais et ici c'est
je regarde quand même
fort voilà et en général c'est quand
même plus fin vous voyez que la tuile
dans la pâte elle est un peu plus fine
au niveau de l'épaisseur celle là il y a
une petite trace d'enghobe on voit on
voit la différence entre l'intérieur qui
est bien rouge une extérieur vous voyez
la trace blanche un peu là c'est un peu
plus clair donc là c'est un engobe qui
était qui avait été appliqué sur
l'amphore et l'engobe après ça se
dégrade assez vite donc en général c'est
pas toujours bien préservé puis c'est
vrai que quand on quand on les lave à la
brosse à dents si on fait pas attention
ça peut ça peut partir vite mais voilà
c'est des petits des petits trucs pour
essayer de les différencier je sais pas
si on fait la différence ou pas
[Musique]
c'est vrai que quand on a la passion de
l'archéologie et qu'on veut s'exercer
c'est compliqué de trouver un chantier
qui accueille les mineurs et justement
ben bibrac comme ça un des seuls en
France on a pas mal de demandes mais je
pense que c'est pour ça que ça marche
autant depuis depuis ces années quoi je
pense que ça a quand même fait ses
preuves d'ailleurs il y a des gens qui
ont fait le chantier école et qui
continuent derrière et qui deviennent
archéologue noir par exemple
j'ai fait ça quand j'avais 16 et 17 ans
je m'appelle Julien je suis pas du tout
dans le monde de l'archéologie et puis
la première image qui me vient quand je
pense à ça c'est Jurassic Park au début
Jurassic Park quand au pinceau il
découvre un os de
dinosaure quoi est-ce que vous avez
réagir ce péché
plus elle pinceau tu vois c'est pas le
dinosaure en soi mais c'est plutôt le
pinceau parce que en archéo on n'utilise
jamais un pinceau ou alors pour faire
joli quand il y a les caméras imagine
Julien tu as pu faire l'expérience tout
à l'heure sur le chantier avec toi ta
perche micro bon imagine TF1 qui arrive
ou France 3 Bourgogne qui débarque ok on
va vous filmer les gars au bout de 2
secondes le perchman il nous arrête fait
vous faites beaucoup trop de bruit avec
vos pioches est-ce que vous pouvez faire
semblant est-ce que vous pouvez faire de
la simulation et d'ailleurs il y a les
fouilleurs qui sont en train de fouiller
mais on fait que de la simulation on
pinceau parce que comme ça ça fait pas
de bruit pas trop de poussière et on
abîme pas la fouille en fait on ne
fouille pas réellement c'est tout
simplement ça désolé de passer des rêves
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'approprier là encore ce monde naturel
parait assez logique il y a vraiment une
ritualisation autour de cette sépulture
néolithique dès qu'on rentre un peu plus
dans le détail de ces architectures on
s'aperçoit que le seul mot munir ne
suffit pas en lui-même et que modo le
même n'est pas une femme
[Musique]